this is a true story this guy that works
with me rich and he had to get I said
I'm gonna he works with me a long time
I'm gonna get your health insurance he
had to go for a physical he never goes
to the doctor he asked me if he's gonna
have to have a prostate check and he was
so nervous about it because he had never
have one for those that haven't had one
it's how do you would anger and the
finger in the butt yeah like you do it
every day
well I'm grown-up anyway he gets checked
constantly right
can't be too safe yeah MOTU most guys
that's a big deal Andy it's like another
day they know what's happening I don't
even know it he's often not at the
doctor just gonna find this out now so
what I did was he had to go get the
checkup because she did physical to get
he had never had this called any found
that was gonna get done and I called as
him when as he left my office to go to
the doctor I called the doctor's office
the receptionist answers and said hello
my name is rich and I have an
appointment at 50 or so yes we see you
you'll should be here in 15 minutes I
said listen are they gonna do a a rectal
exam is it a wreck and she goes yes it's
just part of the routine
I go listen I've never had it done I'm
very uncomfortable I'm gonna show up in
the office in about 5 6 min act like
this never even happened but I'm not
comfortable with a doctor in the room
putting his finger in my ballon I will
not feel comfortable is it possible to
have people in there I like the
receptionist the nurse I don't even care
if it's another patient but I want like
three or four people I will not feel
comfortable in the room with the man
with a finger in there is there any way
you could possibly goes what we've
that's unimpressive but we'll we'll take
care of it and I'll be walking in the
office I'm calling you from my car phone
I'm an act like this never happened but
anyway rich showed up backing out he is
just like shell-shocked I've never seen
you know somebody come back with
post-traumatic stress but rich has it
and I feel responsible but more in the
room with war
we're in the room one finger four people
were in the room but apparently he's
okay it's a normal size and everybody
was happy with how it worked out that's
good
your I guess they all have to deal with
it yeah yeah hence the name of your show
yeah on this channel that you're
watching now here here right now Lauro
at nine don't miss it and tweet with me
live at Howie Mandel just what tweet
with me
oh I tweet yes oh yeah no I tweet too I
didn't know it was a live part of the
process no well the shows on my Twitter
don't aren't i fantastic that's what you
think twitter is for just to resolve
people and say aren't I amazing yes
selfish don't you ever use it to say
isn't how are you amazing oh yeah for
Howie
yeah I'll say you're amazing I will just
probably can't tweet because one finger
is always in your butt right no dictated
to my assistant
you